for democrats dr rick bright
was a star witness a top government
virologist
turned whistleblower who came to capitol
hill to reveal
failings in the trump administration's
handling of the coronavirus crisis
he began with a dire warning there will
be
likely a resurgence of cobit 19 this
fall
it'll be greatly compounded by the
challenges of seasonal influenza
without better planning 2020 could be
the darkest winter in modern history
first and foremost we need to be
truthful with the american people
americans deserve the truth the truth
must be based on science
we have the world's greatest scientists
let us lead
without the truth he said americans were
not as prepared as they could have been
and lives were lost dr bright once ran
the government agency overseeing vaccine
efforts the trump administration
abruptly removed him from the position
last
month he claims his early warnings about
the lack of crucial medical supplies
and the seriousness of what lay ahead
were criticized and ignored
he reflected on emails he received from
a top
u.s medical supplier our a95 respiratory
supply was
was completely decimated and he said
we're in deep the world is
and we need to act and i pushed that
forward to the highest levels i could in
hhs
and got no response from that moment i
knew
that we were going to have a crisis for
our healthcare workers
because we were not taking action we
were already behind the ball
that was our last window of opportunity
to turn on that production
to save the lives of those health care
workers and we didn't act
listening to your testimony gives me
chills because it all adds up to one
inescapable conclusion it didn't have to
be this way
dr bright also believes he was pushed
out because he resisted president
trump's efforts to push
unproven covid19 treatments like the
anti-malarial drug hydroxychloroquine
on the way to a medical equipment
company in pennsylvania president trump
dismissed the government scientists
claims but there are a lot of people
that do not like the job he did
i don't know him i never met him i don't
want to meet him
but i watched him and he looks like an
angry disgruntled employee
who frankly according to some people
didn't do a very good job
i now uh ask for a moment of silence in
honor
of the over 80 000 americans who have
lost their lives
from covet 19. coronavirus still has
america in its grip what this testimony
showed perhaps
most plainly is just how politicized
it has become amanda walker sky news
washington